where we left off in the last video we
were trying to figure out if there's a
meaningful difference between the
proportion of men voting for candidate
and the proportion of women we sampled a
thousand men sampled a thousand women
and we got some a mean a a sample
proportion for each of them we got 0.6
for two for the men and 0.591 for the
women but our goal is is to get a 95%
confidence interval so just based with
our sample just based our actual sample
we got let me write it over here we got
our sample proportion for the men - let
me do this in a neutral color we got our
sample proportion for the men - our
sample proportion for the women being
being let's see 0.6 for two - 0.591
that's point zero five one so this is
zero point zero five one I just
subtracted this from that so what we
want to do and we want a confidence
interval we want to know at some
interval we want some interval we want
to we want to be confident I always have
to say that because we're not it's not
going to be super precise we want to be
confident that there is a 95% chance a
95% chance that this thing right here
remember we take this when we take when
we took the two sample proportions and
took their difference it's like taking a
sample from the sampling distribution of
this statistic so we want a 95% chance
that the true mean or the true value of
this that p1 - p2 is within some range
let's say is within is within D I'll say
D for distance D D of the actual
difference that we got with our samples
within D of I'll write that in green
0.05 1 and I write this multiple times
but I always write it this way I don't
just give the formula that you normally
see in books it's very easy to memorize
if you do but this way you actually see
why why this confidence interval makes
sense if there's a 95% chance that p1
minus p2 the actual true proportions the
difference of the true proportions is
within
d of our actual the difference between
our sample proportions this statement
right here this statement right here is
the same thing that there is a 95%
chance 95% chance chance that zero point
0.05 one is within is within D of this
actual parameter P 1 minus P 2 which is
the same thing as the mean so we need to
figure out some distance we need to
figure out some distance around this
mean we have to figure out some distance
around this mean where there's an if we
take a random sample from this and this
is a random sample from this
distribution that if we take a random
sample from this distribution it has a
95% chance of being within D of this
mean because the if it's within D of the
mean then there's also a 95% chance that
the mean is within D of our sample and
then we'll have our confidence interval
our D our confidence interval will be
dis value plus D and this value minus D
so what are these what is the distance D
well in a normalized normal distribution
I got a Z table right over here and we
can assume everything is normal
especially the sampling distributions
because our n is so big and also our
proportion is not close to 0 or 1 it's
in it's it's nice and close to the
middle so we don't end up with all these
weird cases near the edges we say ok how
do we contain 90 the middle 95% how many
standard deviations in a normal
distribution can we be do we need to be
away from the mean in order to contain
95% of the probability now these Z
tables and we've done it multiple times
give you a cumulative distribution we're
looking for this is e value right over
here if it's containing 95% you're going
to have two and a half percent over here
and you're going to have two and a half
percent two and a half percent over here
so from a Z tables point of view this z
table gives you the cumulative gives you
the cumulative probability up to that Z
value so what we're looking for is
actually 97.5%
we're looking for we're looking for
something that contains all of this over
here 97
97.5% if we get the Z value and then
apply it on both sides then we're going
to have something that contains 95
percent so let's look up the ninety
seven point five ninety seven point five
is right over there and that is 1.96
standard deviations so this is 1.96
naught for a normalized standard
deviation or one z score of 1.96 so if
we look to this normal distribution
right over here this distance this
distance that we care about this
distance is going to be 1.96 times the
standard deviation of this distribution
so it's going to be 1.96 times all of
this business 1.96 times the standard
deviation of this distribution of this
distribution and so we just need to
calculate this and multiply it by 1.96
now we have a problem we don't know the
true parameters P 1 and P 2 we don't
know the true population parameters we
don't know P 1 and P 2 that's the part
of the problem we're trying to figure
out is there a meaningful difference
between P 1 and P 2 but we've seen it
multiple times since our sample size is
large since our sample size is large we
can estimate P 1 and P 2 with our sample
proportions with our sample proportions
so we can say it's going to be
approximately so we could change this
let me use a different color we could
change this to approximately and we can
use our sample proportions use our
sample proportions and we know what
those values aren't actually this n over
here was a thousand was a thousand so
let's figure that out let's just get the
calculator out
let's get the calculator out just going
to be one big calculation here so we
have is the square root the square root
and then in parentheses our sample our
sample proportion for the men is 0.6 for
two 0.6 for two and then we're going to
multiply that times 1 - let me get the
parentheses there so times 1 1 minus
point 6 4 2 close parentheses
these close parentheses that's that over
there divided by a thousand divided by
1000 and then we're going to add to that
plus do the same thing for the women our
sample proportion is 0.591 0.591
x times c times 1 minus 0.5 9 1 so
that's this term right over here divided
by a thousand once again I need to get
the parentheses right divided by 1000
and then we just need to close the
parentheses its original parenthesis
because we're taking the square root of
everything we are taking the square root
of everything so we get point zero to
one
or maybe we'll say point zero to two
point zero to two so this value right
here is approximately this value right
here is approximately zero point zero to
two so going back to our question or
this distance that we care about this
value is going to be approximately or
our best estimate of it is zero point
zero to two so let's just multiply that
zero point zero to two times one point
nine six so let's just multiply it times
one point nine six gives us point zero
four zero point zero four three I'll
just round it so this is equal to this
right here is equal to point or zero
point zero four three and just like that
we have our confidence interval we know
that there's a 95% chance there's a 95%
chance that our that are the true
difference of the proportions is within
0.043 is within 0.043 of the actual
difference of our sample proportions
that we got or if we actually want to
get an interval we take this value minus
0.04 three so let's do that so we could
have 0.05
five one 0.05 one minus 0.04 three minus
0.04 three is going to give us point
zero zero eight and then if we add it so
point zero five one plus 0.04 3 gives us
0.09 four so the true the true or the
95% confidence interval between the
proportions of men and the proportion of
women or we're going to vote for the
candidate 95% confidence interval
confidence interval interval is between
before for p1 minus p2 is zero point
zero zero eight to zero point zero nine
four have it right here on the
calculator and we're done so it does
seem where we're confident that there's
a 95% chance that men are definitely
going to are more likely to vote for the
candidate than women